hello John Perry here welcome back to
what's it Wednesday last week specimen
was as many of you guessed lots of you
guessed he was a crow just a common
American crow the first person to get
that right was YouTube user stupenda
miss geographic Asst and by the way you
were also the one that got last week's
right first so you're on a roll
good work my friend good work by the way
crows are super rad I love them but
that's besides the point today we're
gonna start a brand new segment monthly
monsters how this works is I'm going to
take a monster hoax from the past
actually some of these aren't even hoax
is there like accidents like people
people found dead animals and they
thought oh my gosh that's a monster or
an alien or something and then I got on
the news and there became this big thing
on the internet so a lot of these if you
follow this sort of thing regularly a
lot of these things you'll already know
because you've already followed them and
if you happen to know this one already
please don't play just in the comments a
oh I already know what that is but don't
tell everybody what it is because what I
want everyone to do is I'm going to show
you an animal carcass and it's a little
bit gross compared to just looking at
skulls because we're actually looking at
in this case a bloated carcass from the
side of a river we're gonna look at this
carcass and what you're allowed to do is
you're allowed to do a google image
search for any animal that you want so
you can do that and you can do a google
image search for any skull of any animal
that you want but you can't look up
alien hoaxes or whatever you have to
just look up animals or their bones
because if you look up you know alien
hoaxes you'll find this right away but
what I want you to be able to do is get
good at identifying things that people
think are aliens or think our monsters
get good at trying to figure out what
they actually are so here we have this
month's monster fake monster people
thought that this was an alien because
it looks a lot like et this was in
Panama
where this was discovered and the big
clue for me was the claws on the hand
some kids claimed to have found it and
it was it attacked them they claimed and
they threw rocks at it that's one of the
stories that I read online
there was other stories too but that was
the main story I kept hearing I don't
think the story is true I think they
found it and it was already dead and
they got took pictures of it and got
scared and ran away but they said that
it had three fingers on each hand and on
each foot and that there were long claws
on each hand and on each foot and that
was the clue that helped me figure out
what this is also this was in Panama so
that's another clue what types of
animals are common in Panama and have
big claws so anyway I bet you can figure
this out again do some Google image
searching to try and figure it out
that's the best thing to do to not look
up alien hoaxes or alien Panama don't do
that you will find it right away
and that's cheating so don't cheat but
yeah let me know what you think this is
in the comments section and tell me what
your reasoning is that's what I'm really
interested in knowing tell me what you
think it is and why so I'm excited to
see people you know participate in this
this is really cool all right next week
I will reveal what this mystery monster
is and then we'll do another skull so
what's it Wednesday all right
[Music]